it's been over 30 years since Crockett
and Tubbs last on their pastels and
saved the day on Miami Vice but just
where have the cast of this 1980s mega
hit gone in the years following the
show's finale here's what the cast of
Miami Vice are up to today
once he donned Sonny Crockett's
legendary Ray Bans Don Johnson became
one of the biggest stars on television
Crockett nails every great cop story
trope a rogue whose code clashes with
department bureaucracy check a
tough-as-nails exterior hiding a wounded
heart double check the coolest guy in
the room right up until it's time to
deal some justice to the criminal
underworld triple check
Crockett's intense charisma and
undeniable badassery makes him the focus
of Miami vices universe and a
straight-up icon to boot after his time
as Crockett ended Johnson tried to jump
to leading man status on the big screen
unfortunately films such as the hot spot
and Harley Davidson and the Marlboro Man
failed to impress critics or blow up the
box office his next big success was back
on television as the lead on CBS police
drama Nash Bridges which matched Miami
vices five-year runnin length if not an
impact the 2000s saw Johnson bouncing
between supporting roles but 2019
offered up something of a renaissance
for the actor as he played major parts
in two critically hailed projects Bryan
Johnson's twisty murder mystery knives
out and HBO's prestige series Watchmen
he'll next appear in rebel Ridge and
upcoming Netflix thriller by director
Jeremy Saulnier
detective Ricardo Rico Tubbs played by
Philip Michael Thomas is the yin to
Crockett's yang a transplant from the
NYPD he quickly finds himself seduced by
the Vice side of his work often engaging
in off-duty relationships with persons
of interest and even fathering a child
with the daughter of drug lord Esteban
Calderon still when the chips are down
he always has Crockett's back Philip
Michael Thomas brought a huge sense of
style to the part forever searing tubs
into the public consciousness
sadly Thomas never quite followed up on
the momentum from his time as Tubbs he
released a pair of albums starred in a
short-lived Italian TV series called
detective extra-large and fronted the
Philip Michael Thomas international
psychic Network which is exactly what it
sounds like Thomas also briefly reunited
with Johnson on a couple of Nash Bridges
episodes at this point though he's
likely best known to younger audiences
as the voice of Lance Vance in the
colossal II successful grand theft auto
vice city games despite claiming he was
retired from acting after the release of
2006 his grand theft auto vice city
stories Thomas returned to the digital
realm one more time for 2011 s Gangstar
Rio city of Saints every deeply wounded
detective needs a good love interest and
Crockett's came in the form of detective
Gina calibrating the pair's on-again
off-again affair is a central plot point
of the series only ending when Calabrese
eventually calls it quits
they do however remain close and their
paths continue to cross on a number of
investigations and while the 80s weren't
always kind to female characters on TV
Gina Calabrese stands out as one of the
most dependable detectives in the Metro
Dade Police Department
Sandra Santiago has continued to work on
television long after the end of Miami
Vice
her next big gig was a three-year stint
on the soap opera guiding light followed
by appearances on a number of well-known
shows including damages true detective
and Gotham her most well known post vice
role however was as Tony Soprano's
next-door neighbor Jeannie cusimano
on HBO's mega hit Mafia show The
Sopranos Broadway fans might also have
seen her in the well-regarded and Tony
winning nine which starred Antonio
Banderas
her most recent TV appearance was on the
CBS political drama Madam Secretary in
2017 detective lieutenant Marty Castillo
is not your typical cop show boss
while most authority figures in this
kind of show make the protagonists lives
harder Castillo is totally loyal to his
team willing to go out on a limb to aid
their investigations or help them
navigate bureaucratic roadblocks he's
also a formidable police officer often
drawing on his experience as a DEA
operative and edward james olmos as I
see intense performance makes Castillo
and ever compelling presence on the show
I know you all heard inside but do your
grieving in private the street has no
sympathy
not many Miami Vice viewers would have
predicted that almost would go on to
have the most prestigious career among
the show's cast but that's exactly how
it's played out after turning down the
lead on Star Trek The Next Generation
almost was nominated for an Oscar for
his turn as Jaime Escalante in the 1988
film Stand and Deliver from there he's
worked almost constantly appearing in
films such as Selena and American me and
on highly regarded TV shows such as The
West Wing his best-known effort though
was his starring role as Admiral William
Adama in Battlestar Galactica almost
most recently appeared on Mayans MC and
has several in production projects going
so you can be sure you'll be seeing much
more of him in the near future
played by Gregory Sierra Liu Rodriguez
is the vice team's original superior
officer he and Crockett are implied to
have a long history having worked
together for several years before the
series takes place while Rodriguez can
be quick to anger he steps up when it
matters giving his life by taking a
bullet from hitman Luda Viji Armstrong
his death is a major early plot point
for the show serving as the catalyst for
Crockett and Tubbs to head to the
Bahamas to confront drug lord Esteban
Calderon Sierra had a lengthy list of
credits before Miami Vice with episodic
appearances in everything from the
action-packed Mission Impossible in
Hawaii five-o to sitcoms like Sanford &
Son and all in the family his longest
run on a series was as Chano almond wale
on Barney Miller but he worked steadily
through the 90s popping up on the
x-files
Star Trek Deep Space Nine and The Fresh
Prince of Bel Air he also had parts on
the big screen in hotshots part deux and
a low-down dirty shame this millennium
he appeared in 2018 s the other side of
the wind the Orson Welles directed film
that was finished and released thirty
years after its creators death detective
Trudy Joplin is Gina caliber a C's
partner and one of two female members of
the vice team like detective Calabrese
she starts out as a lure in prostitution
sting operations attracting would be
John's with her provocative outfits over
time her role shifts into that of the
team's intelligence gatherer
using her street-level contacts and
computer skills to provide the in-depth
info needed to bring down Miami's worst
criminals although she rarely goes out
on undercover work she does get her
hands dirty from time to time posing as
Tubbs wife to help flush out a DEA leak
in the episode smugglers blues and
posing again as a prostitute to nab a
serial killer in Asian cut Brown had a
bit of a character resume before Miami
Vice which she parlayed into frequent
work throughout the 90s she had
recurring roles on designing women' and
Lois & Clark
and showed up on individual episodes of
The Fresh Prince of Bel Air and Family
Matters among others she was most
recently seen in the holiday-themed film
2017 s our dream Christmas detectives
Larry Zito and Stan's white ex serve as
Miami vices surveillance outfit staking
out potential suspects and engaging in
electronic and audio intelligence
gathering Zito is originally played as
comic relief but as the show's tone
grows more serious so too does John
deals performance unfortunately deal
tired of the role leading to Zito's
cocaine overdose death during an
undercover investigation of a drug
runner after leaving Miami Vice Steele
temporarily forewent television work to
focus on theater he found time however
to advance his film career in a rash of
movies throughout the 90s in fact deal
has one of the deepest resumes of any
Miami Vice alum with literally dozens of
credits per year up through 20/20 post
Vice he appeared in the Hanoi Hilton Mo
Money and Stargate sg-1 among many many
other productions the turn of the
millennium saw him return actively to TV
with a recurring role on the shield and
episodic appearances on the likes of
NYPD Blue and the West Wing his list of
movie credits is also dotted with
well-known titles from Oliver Stone's
Nixon in which he played G gordon Liddy
to Jurassic Park 3 despite his
occasional goofiness Michael Talbots
stance Y Tech is an effective part of
the team using his surveillance
expertise alongside Larry Zito to great
effect his close bond with his partner
means that Zito's death hits him
particularly hard things eventually gets
so bad that swai tech finds himself on
the hook to some pretty nefarious
characters who attempt to leverage the
formerly fun-loving detective
to compromising his squad Miami Vice
wasn't Michael Talbots first rodeo the
actor had already appeared in a variety
of TV shows including mash as well as in
movies such as Carrie and first blood
unfortunately things never really took
off for tell that once his time in South
Beach came to an end
he has since kept active however as an
outspoken supporter of the National
Rifle Association during their time
battling crime in Miami the vice squad
runs up against plenty of hardened
criminals
Isidore izzy Moreno is not one of them
after being arrested by Crockett and
Tubbs on a botched bank robbery Moreno
sings like a bird
receiving immunity in exchange for
information from there he embarks on a
long relationship with the show's leads
getting off the hook from his ridiculous
crimes in exchange for giving up the
goods on some of Miami's most dangerous
shirkers at the law with his penchant
for dropping literary mists quotes in
his thick accent Moreno is often used as
comic relief but his staying power is
undeniable in fact he's the only
character outside of the main cast to
appear in every one of the show's
seasons martin ferrero had a solid
career in TV that continued after Miami
Vice Landing him on shows like the
x-files as well as reuniting him with
Don Johnson on Nash Bridges he also
enjoyed some success at the movies in
the 90s appearing in stop or my mom will
shoot get Shorty and gods and monsters
the role from which you probably most
recognize him however is a little more
ignominy
Ferraro played Gennaro the lawyer who
gets bitten in half by a t-rex while
sitting on a toilet in 1993's Jurassic
Park in a case of life imitating art
musician Sheena Easton plays popstar
caitlin Davies on Miami Vice who later
becomes Caitlin Davies Crockett the
detectives second wife originally paired
when Crockett is appointed to bodyguard
Davies while she awaits testimony
against her former manager the two start
off with the degree of animosity that
masks a deep attraction eventually they
fall in love and marry but their
relationship while passionate is dotted
with tension due to each of their
careers fortunately it all
seems to work out until it doesn't and
caitlyn dies and Crockett's arms after
being gunned down by an old enemy easton
has held down a number of acting gigs
over the years including as a voice on
the much-loved animated series gargoyles
and on syndicated sci-fi shows such as
Highlander the series her acting career
however is only a blip when compared to
what she's accomplished in the world of
music Easton is a six-time Grammy
nominee and two-time winner the singer
of 80s hits like morning train
nine-to-five and princes you got the
look and cellar of over 20 million
records and singles worldwide while she
hasn't released any new music since 2000
Eston remains very active as a performer
even taking to the stage in London's
West End into 2016 revival of 42nd
Street check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
you